this is everything we want to see in the
new Harry Potter series would you
believe us if we said that Ron was a
great wizard in the books he truly is
seriously yes but the movies decided to
make him comic relief for some reason
could we Panic now his heroic moments
were more often than not given to
Hermione like when he stands on a broken
leg to protect Harry from serious and
Prisoner of Azkaban instead Hermione
does this in the movie you want to kill
Harry you'll have to kill us too nobody
really knows why this change was made
although some have suggested that it
could have something to do with
screenwriter Steve cloves admitting that
Hermione was his favorite character
whether or not this is true we're still
hoping to see a more book accurate
version of Ron in the HBO series this is
HBO's chance to give us an entirely new
Wizarding World